eu leaders have rejected a plan to hold
talks with russia's vladimir putin
france and germany made the proposal but
it got plenty of backlash from baltic
countries at a summit in brussels
and there was another topic dividing
member states what to do about a new law
in hungary
that critics say is homophobic more than
half of eu leaders condemn the
legislation calling it discrimination
that goes against eu values well
hungary's
prime minister victor orban says he has
no intention of changing the law
rainbow-colored rage at what's seen as a
hungarian attack on fundamental rights
stole the spotlight at a european union
summit that was to be dominated by
efforts to deal with the coronavirus
crisis
and its economic consequences as he
arrived in brussels hungarian prime
minister victor orban faced
calls for his country's expulsion from
the eu
for a new law that bans any portrayal of
homosexuality to minors
many leaders confronted orban directly
in the meeting
some of them quite emotionally belgian
prime minister alexandre de crow says
he was surprised by what he called the
quasi-unanimous opposition
we have clearly pointed out to orban
this is a line in the sand
you've gone too far and this law is
unacceptable
more than half of leaders signed a
letter underscoring the eu principle of
non-discrimination over sexual
orientation and gender identity the
european commission has already begun a
legal procedure against budapest over
the legislation
another departure from the planned
agenda on russian relations
a last-minute franco-german proposal to
invite vladimir putin to a summit
that suggestion failed to gain support
to the german chancellor chagrin
we couldn't agree today to immediately
meet at the high level
at the leaders level but for me it's
important that the format of a dialogue
will be further investigated i
personally would have wished for a more
courageous step
but it's good as it is so this is
awkward lithuanian president kitanas
nauseata
is also pleased with the outcome because
the proposal failed
i think it's too early because we
so far we don't see any radical changes
of behavior of patent of behavior
vladimir putin
and to try to
engage is of course very good idea but
to engage without any deadlines without
any preconditions
of course it would be a very wrong
signal i would say
leaders did cover other subjects on
migration they focused on how to stop it
at its source
and on the coronavirus they called for
more solidarity and coordination on
efforts to fight the pandemic
and to reopen travel next up prospects
and
programs for economic recovery
let's go right to brussels our bureau
chief alexander fanon is standing by for
us there good morning alexandra
i want to ask you about the two big
topics dividing member states first of
all the question of a possible summit
with vladimir putin there was no
agreement on this issue
why is that well we have to understand
first of all that this was a last minute
pitch by
germany and france and that was
presented shortly before the summit
started
many eu leaders felt blindsided saying
why is it justified to have this idea
right now
only because the u.s president met with
vladimir putin
we have to understand that high-level
talks between eu leaders and
the russian president were suspended
after the annexation of crimea
since then the relations got even worse
so that is why
many eu leaders among them many in
eastern europe are saying it's too early
to talk about that
first we have to see a change of
behavior
and concessions from the kremlin okay
let's talk about the other topic the
lgbtq law in hungary that's very
controversial we know
viktor orban is not backing down eu
leaders many of them saying
it is homophobic and i want to play you
what the dutch prime minister had to say
for many people ask me hungary no longer
has a place in the eu
but unfortunately with the system we
have i can't or the other 26 member
states can't just tell them to leave
that needs to be done step by step and
in the meantime we hope they'll adapt
alexander that is a pretty bold
statement from the dutch prime minister
that hungary
may not have a place in the eu anymore
so how is this issue going to play out
well this is a very bold statement
indeed and i i think it's fair to assume
that other eu leaders were thinking
the same when they had this heated
emotional discussion
about a new law in hungary but we have
to say that this is of course up to
hungary to decide whether they would
like to stay in the european union or
not
and now after this very heated summit we
are sort of
to speak back to business the european
commission has announced he
that it is triggering legal proceedings
over this new legislation
in hungary however in the past we also
saw that hungary tends to ignore
court rulings but there is a new
mechanism a new rule of law mechanism
linked to eu funds it's not in place
at the moment but it will be soon so we
definitely
expect to see a decision by the european
commission
to freeze eu funds uh this being
distributed to hungary
if there is a lack of democratic values
in this country
you called it a heated summit i mean
what did these disagreements tell us
about the state of unity
in the european union well i think
it's telling us a lot about the problems
and challenges the european union is
facing
it was meant to be a club of democracies
you know a counter model to
dictatorships and and
authoritarian regimes elsewhere not
within the bloc and now the european
union is
facing authoritarian tendencies within
the club
and it's just uh the whole thing is
telling us that the european union is
not well equipped
to to to counter such authoritarian and
democratic
moves measures within the european union
okay last question alexander considering
those struggles do you think there's any
prospect of a concrete outcome
on these topics well we actually have a
few concrete outcomes uh we have
uh um the decision to look look into
further punitive measures with regard to
russia the european union wants
to work closely together with the
countries
who can help to stem migration and
the eu leaders are quite united when it
comes to covet and how to
fight future pandemics our brussels
bureau chief alexander fundament
reporting for us there thank you very
much
you